and i know people are frustrated at the
prospect of further restrictions
but i want to reassure you that we have
a comprehensive plan
to protect jobs and businesses in every
region and nation
of the united kingdom our winter economy
plan has three parts
first the job support scheme will
protect jobs
whether your business is open or closed
if your business can open safely but
with reduced or uncertain demand
the government will directly subsidize
people's wages
over the winter giving businesses the
option
to bring people back to work on shorter
hours
rather than making them redundant that's
the right approach
for businesses who can remain open
but businesses who are being asked to
close will need further support
so on friday i announced that we're
expanding the job support scheme
if the closures mean you are unable to
work for one week or more
your employer will still be able to pay
you two thirds of your normal salary
and the uk government will cover the
cost
this national program will benefit
people
the same wherever they live and whatever
job
they do the existing furlough scheme
continues throughout
october with the new job support scheme
available from november
so there is no gap in support
and to give people and businesses
certainty the scheme will run
for six months through to next spring
the job support scheme is in line with
most other major european countries
and to support the lowest paid through
this crisis
we have also made our welfare system
more generous
and more responsive too second
businesses in england who are legally
required to close
can now claim a cash grant of up to 3
000 pounds
per month depending on the value of
their business premises
those grants can be used for any
business costs and will never need to be
repaid
and i'm guaranteeing an extra 1.3
billion pounds of funding
to the scottish welsh and northern
ireland administrations
if they choose to do something similar
third the prime minister has announced
today we are providing additional
funding
for local authorities for local
authorities entering
level three we're providing up to half a
billion pounds
to fund activities like enforcement
compliance
and contact racing and to protect vital
services
we're providing around a billion pounds
of additional funding
for all local authorities on top of the
3.7 billion pounds
we've already provided since march
our winter economy plan will give people
and businesses
flexibility and certainty over the
coming months
whether they are open or required to
close
all part of our plan to protect the jobs
and livelihoods of the british people